president biden and first lady jill
biden visited the community yesterday
and met with the families of victims it
was the president's second trip to the
site of a mass shooting this month he
was met with demands for action on gun
violence in america omar villafranca has
the latest from uvalde where anger over
the police response is growing omar good
morning
good morning people in uvalde saw
investigators change and update the
details of what happened here several
times last week and while families are
grieving they're now demanding answers
and accountability
an emotional crowd in uvalde urged
president biden to do something
following the horrifying elementary
school shooting that killed 19 children
and two of their teachers his response
[Applause]
we will as he and the first lady paid
their respects to the innocent people
murdered at rob elementary school adding
a bouquet of white flowers to the
growing memorial
thousands of children and adults from
across the state joined them many
waiting in line for two hours in nearly
100 degree heat i really like this
who did you bring it for
the 19 kids and the two teachers
law enforcement's delayed response to
the shooting is still drawing intense
scrutiny and condemnation the timeline
of events shows police waited outside
the classroom for nearly an hour even as
children inside repeatedly called 9-1-1
federal tactical teams were ordered by
local officers not to enter the room
when they arrived before opting to
breach it on their own and kill the
gunman on friday the director of texas
department of public safety said this
about the decision to wait of course it
was not the right decision it was a
wrong decision period there's no no
excuse for that the decision to wait
runs contrary to the state's active
shooter response training which the
district went through in march it states
the best hope that innocent victims have
is that officers immediately move into
action to isolate distract or neutralize
the threat
even if that means one officer acting
alone martin fierro's daughter eliana
survived the shooting families were
fighting to get in the shooter had an
hour almost an hour 40 minutes and
you know
people were fighting and so so the
there's a lot of questions right now now
the department of justice will try to
answer those questions as it reviews the
police response the city's mourning the
city is we're shocked among those
demanding answers is uvalde county
commissioner ronald garza it's obvious
that there were some errors made
but we need to learn from those errors
was there a failure in security
measures that's coming to light too yes
as the investigation continues some
families here in uvalde are getting
ready for funerals for the victims which
are expected to happen later on this
week
nikki
our thoughts are with all those families
omar thank you